I want to know how do you overcome fear
some day I hope you can I said okay okay
how do you overcome fear hey you day um
you know I actually I've used it for
that amazing guy dr. King Martin Luther
King and he says if you wanted you want
to climb the giant golden staircase you
have to take the first step and this you
know amazingly symbolic but you have to
take the first step and I tell you what
right so if you have to fire an employee
don't do on a monday because i guarantee
you'll spend the whole weekend worrying
about it and then you won't have that
conversation a tough conversation and
then you push it out and you'll let the
performance issue fester and you've just
got to take these things head-on and
you've got to be true to yourself and
you've got to be honest to yourself but
it's always about you just take in that
first step so how do you overcome fear
the only way you do it is practice
practice practice practice practice and
what is it it means and they've all said
rory mcilroy you know I get lucky it
more attractive and more I get lucky and
this practice the more you practice the
more you fail the more you experienced
more you explore the more you adventure
the more you have conviction of relief
and that is the best way to overcome
fear I think with fear too I think
people feel like you're not supposed to
be afraid like beer is normal when
you're trying something new and you
don't have experience and you're going
to be afraid it's feeling that fear and
doing it anyway and the thing at least
that helps me get through it is I try to
imagine myself when I'm you know 80
years old looking back in my life there
by the time I get there I'm on my mom
when I'm on my deathbed it might be like
200 years old by the time I get up there
with all our technology and everything
but you know I'm on my deathbed looking
back on my life and I want to have a few
regrets as possible and that's the thing
that helps me get through my fear like
will I regret not doing this well I
regret bowing down or bowing out or not
talking to that person I'm not taking my
chains will I regret it and yes it's
super scary but for me that feeling of
looking back in my life and feel like
I'm gonna regret
not taking this shot now that gives me
the courage to beat that fear and then
once you do it once it's just like
training the muscle becomes a lot easier
the next time we do is easier the next
time you know it's easier for me
speaking on stage I was super nervous
the first time I did it I secretly hoped
that they would call me and cancel and
say listen Evan you know conferences off
don't worry about it they go great you
know but didn't cancel i went and and I
was super nervous but now the next
conference becomes easier the next comes
becomes easier and you know maybe when
I'm speaking in front of a stadium a
50,000 people maybe I'll get nervous on
that one right but then the next time do
that it'll be easier and so to stevens
point about practice practice practice
like you just take the first step and
then the next step becomes easier and
the next that becomes easier and that
huge thing that is insurmountable it's
now broken down hey i'm going to ask one
panna a bit of shameless navy open we
had Gwenyth Paltrow here and after that
a conversation with them and we're
talking about shoes talking about how
she's you gobbs you're very successful
business and she loves an actress and
incredible actor but in terms of one of
the aspects you sort of struggle with
initially which is now absolutely kind
of militant about is planning and
there's a will give you something and we
talked about it before the power of
visualization is the in terms of
planning and check it out the web as
well there's a phrase called in state
planet and it's used in sport in
business and everything so Usain Bolt he
doesnt sit down in the locker room and
it's a dark locker room is closed iphone
on listening to music what he's doing is
imagine himself crossing that on for me
the line faster than V else and he
actually goes back every 10 meters and
it mentions exactly what he does so if
you fear anything the best way to
overcome it is practice and the best way
without the actual practice is
visualization but you always start with
the end-to-end say planning start with
you into 100 meters you've got a hundred
thousand people in Rio at the Olympics
cheering you screaming your name and you
ask what did I have to do every metre of
that journey meter 99 meter 98 meter how
did I come out of starting blocks and
then you visualize you you played the
movie in your head you know what the
answer is and you just hit the blocks
and you just go for gold so it's really
powerful there's also this arm you
teach yourself this critical there's a
single future perfect past tense so you
actually and it could be like a business
meeting could be a pitch it could be a
presentation so you do a presentation
you say write what I want to do is come
out of that room with a presentation
done for a sales order where I've got
those prospective customers clapping
cheering and applauding and show me love
and say they want to buy my fries we got
a view product then think about what is
it we would have had to done to achieve
that so what we will it will have had to
have done to pee success what what do I
need I've got the order in my hand I've
left the meeting the CFO is signed the
paperwork there and then because you
love my product so much so what were
what would we are mounted on to assure
him of that what is his issues are going
to be and then smash it his issues and
just imagine yourself plan that movie
and even you know test drive it with a
buddy so I want you to see it between
your six you know prospect customers and
just run through do a dry run and you
always get feedback to improve but key
about the power of visualization it
transcends for it transcends business
imagine you've ended up with shoot
success with a huge smile on your face
and your customers with Raven fans and
walk out with that order just think
about what it would have taken because
if you you know think about the other
way around you sit here I'm going a big
pitch I'm gonna try and sell you know
fifty thousand dollar a piece of
equipment or whatever and all you think
is oh my god that's so scary but if you
think wow we've done it we got the deal
smashed it knock them all out the park
mentally your whole fear dissipates away
and then it's always about the plan for
success and then you can be successful
I'm going practice and do it